je ne dis pas que par exemple le poète
qu'on a pu dire détient seule la vérité
ou la direccte et la plus haute était
jeudi qu'il détient une part de la
vérité excède par lan est particulière
elle est spécifique et que la
méconnaître ccse c'est perdre beaucoup
ne l'oubliez c'est grave une société qui
un peuple qui perd sa poésie perd son
âme et il ya beaucoup de fantasmes et de
malentendus sur la poésie sur l'écriture
et ils sont contradictoires certains
vont vous dire que le poème comme vous
dites un poème court comme ça s'annonce
vraiment beaucoup de travail et c'est
qu'ils croient que c'est facile car il
suffit de se mettre devant une feuille
et d'écrire du sentiment par exemple que
ça devienne qui fait qui fait donc une
idée qui fait abstraction de tout le
travail d'élaboration de savoir de deux
lectures avant tout des z'arts leur lieu
de formation
on n'a pas de conservatoire poésie et on
imagine mal et c'est à dire que c'est en
ça que il y a quelque chose de
particulier pour la poésie c'est que
c'est le seul des arts keane qui n'est
pas un lieu de 1 lieu au but
d'objectivation si je puis dire voilà le
seul c'est dans le livre c'est le choix
d hitler qui reconnaissent la valeur dad
d'une écriture poétique et ça fait que à
la fois ça fait sa force
c'est d'ailleurs c'est l'art le plus
partagé qui au bout du compte dans les
gens sentent le plus proche
contrairement à tous les préjugés et en
même temps en même temps l'envers de ça
c'est qu'il a moins de légitimité
socialement
[Musique]
la récitation traditionnelle dans sa
forme primitive vous apprenez temps
devrait vous le dites la semaine
prochaine dans l'intention rien à dire
dans les faits irène plus difficile
quand les femmes et occasion en échec
les trois quarts des élèves
parce que dira dire parler devant un
public c'est déjà difficile
et quand on a six ou sept ans seulement
parce que les autres sont pas des
copains à ce moment là même si c'est
tous des copains
donc vous avez un petit bonhomme petites
nanas de 2,8 de 8 9 ans vous leur faites
dire un poème pas facile de victor hugo
ou d'odile bikutsi mais on peut apporter
et saisir c'est pas le rythme habituel
c'est pas le vocabulaire qu'on utilise
tous les jours c'est déjà difficile est
pris il faut le dire devant dans un
espace qui fait 10 m 15 m de profondeur
avec eux 39 25 élèves
c'est très difficile j pas que c'est
absurde
au contraire je suis je militerai pour
un conditions on ait appris à faire et
qu'on est donnée aux enfants de moyens
que ce soit un plaisir ne fait qu'une
chose lisait un poème à vos élèves tous
les jours mais pas seulement un poème un
poème attendu un poème gentil apem
facile un poème c'est à dire lisent
leurs maïakovski neruda je sais pas
d'extrait d'homère via et puis vous
allez à prêcher pas la fontaine et les
gens de la fontaine voulu fêter suivre
de paul eluard ils ont tous les jours ça
à l'oreille au bout l'oreille elle est
pas elle et elle est intelligente et et
l'âme des enfants est intelligent c'est
à dire aller percer l hyper sensible à
ça elle va entendre que là il ya une
langue dans toutes ces choses
différentes
si différentes imaginez le la fontaine
eluard ou l'odyssée mais il ya une chose
commune il ya une chose comme une et des
enfants le perçoivent parfaitement
c'était dans tous ces gens là c'est pelé
poète parle une langue qui n'est pas
attendu qu'il nage libre qui n'ont rien
prévu
et à chaque fois nouvelles personnes
source de toutes les tout le reste
quelle est la vraie vie telle est la
question des poètes la vraie vie la
vraie vie est ailleurs des bretons et et
c'était le thème de rimbaud de qu'est ce
que c'est que la vraie vie et voulait
changer la vie oui c'est dire parce que
le grain grand danger c'est que notre
vie soit molle soit dans des fonctions
de soi d'un soir et j soit déterminée
soit 100 événements en quelque sorte ou
avec des événements forts comment que je
veux dire factice la vraie vie elle est
ailleurs
la vraie vie elle n'est pas dans le
faire beaucoup de choses s'agitent et
avoir sa rolex à 40 ans houllier ce que
veut dire la vie n est pas là c'est ce
que nous disaient prêts depuis toujours
les vraie vie elle est d'une manière de
d'une manière intense d'être au monde
d'être présent aux choses aux êtres à ce
qui nous entoure a sa propre à son
propre destin dans une conscience
suraigu très tôt et constante de la mort
celui qui sait condamné tout d'un coup
tout d'un coup et 10 touches en jeu et
chaque instant chaque instant est un est
une éternité est une vie pleine et là on
vit et qu'est ce que c'est que cet
instant vip le vécu pleinement
c'est ce que plaide grève la position
convives tous intensément chaque instant
school et rimbaud un absolu de la vie
est belle de leuze 10e le style dont on
tient la position sur le monde
deleuze 10s du type branchement
électrique oui il s'agit d'une vie en
haute tension de la vie politique n'est
ce pas alors est ce qu'on peut vivre
tout le temps comme ça on peut mais en
vivre toujours à haute tension c'est
socialement est possible parce qu'en peu
france on a obligé de vivre en basse
tension entendait dans le système social
ne s'assure pas prendre le billet de bus
ou là et si on le vit toujours à haute
tension se brûle comme tout comme la
surtension voyez antonin artaud juillet
gérard de nerval je parle des poètes et
de tous les artistes qui vivent sur
tensions dans l'absolu de la vie ou
alors est un moment comme rimbaud c'est
plus qu'au 6 bis bar à lait cherchons
lier cherchons de la bassée pour trouver
du de l'inconnu comme il le dit
c'est sa mémé que disait je crois que
c'est mais c'est qu'ils ont vécue par
ton partons dans un baiser vers
l'inconnu je sais pas quoi dire
lisez les mêmes idées que c'est nous
pouvons tous vivre ces instants
d'intensité dans les moments de crue de
l'existence dons qui sont des moments de
d'amour alors ça peut être l'amour sans
ce habituel du terme mais c'est aussi
l'amour dans tout ce qui est pourrait
dire érotisation de la vie il ya les
l'événement du en ou du tour d'immenses
exaltation de bonheur terra devant un
paysage un matin au soleil qui n'est
devant la mer oui et ce que je veux dire
quand j'ai dit ça tout le monde comprend
16 ans ces instants là qu'on dit magique
quand il faudra en fond il nous restitue
quoi l'essentiel de l'est de la vie
quand la vie est vibrante et donc quand
je dis que l'on passe à côté de notre
vie c'est que évidemment peut pas vivre
toujours comme ça mais ne vivra jamais
comme ça c'est ne pas vivre ce ne vire
qu'une vie mort alors là il faut le dire
sans ménagement et je le dis sans
ménagement d'ailleurs mon prochain
bouquin qui paraît de très très bientôt
mais s'intitule levé vous du tombeau il
ne fait que commenter ce que ce propos
là
c'est un fantasme est une idée fausse
c'est un préjugé le plus bête qui soit
l'idée reçue type bouvard et pécuchet la
fameuse la fameuse sentence
les gens n'aiment pas la position
intéresse personne
c'est absurde c'est tout le contraire le
printemps des poètes à prouver il suffit
d'aller n'importe où vous dites après
maujean à bord bercy n'est pas forcément
le poème de ggp a pas forcément demain
dès l'aube ou mignonne allons voir si la
rose vous leur dites un poème
d'apollinaire ou un poème d'aragon
qu'ils connaissent pas et il vous écoute
ils vous disent merci donc et tous les
journalistes qui ont évacué la poésie
des pages culture etc
il regarde dans les yeux et je dis vous
pouvez me dire que les gens n'aiment pas
la poésie vous vous n'aimez pas vous la
lisez pas mais nous partout on fait des
lectures
aujourd'hui il ya plein de jeunes poètes
il ya du monde il ya plus de lecteurs de
poésie aujourd'hui qu'elle n'a jamais
eue
je vous assure on a les preuves regardez
le nombre de livres de poésie qui se
vendent même à 300 exemplaires chez un
petit éditeur ok 300 ampleur ont mis les
petits des leaders il n'y a pas un pays
où l'on dira autant de petits éditeurs
pose y en a partout et et vous accumulez
tout ça plus les gros éditeurs qui
continue moi je travaille chez gallimard
on en manque quand même toutes les
semaines beaucoup 1,2 des milliers de
livres de poésie toutes les semaines bon
donc y'a des gens aient jamais jamais eu
autant comment j'avais 18 ans je dis
j'ai un copain une fois mais dire quand
j'avais 17 18 ans moi j'étais fond de
poésie dans mon lycée blaise pascal à
clermont ferrand
mais d autres s'en foutait l'écouté des
beatles il disait pas comme moi marc
jacobs eluard à apollinaire moi c'était
ma passion
pas vraiment bon là dessus j'étais un
peu inadapté
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai en plus
tout est facile il y en a tellement faut
tout lire
en vrac moi je dis lisez tout en vrac
les yeux fermés si je peux dire allez-y
2d classique du contemporain ensemble il
faut je parlais tout à l'heure de
ronsard faut dire on sert du bellay en
même temps que le buzz aujourd'hui que
ces mêmes monde il élit la langue est
différente oui lien qui est plus
ancienne mais à part ça c'est pas de
problème de l'ancienneté c'est tout
poète à une langue différente
il faut toujours apprendre à apprivoiser
la langue du poète et c'est normal qu'un
pote dérange surprennent mais parce
qu'il parle pas comme tout le monde
si on parle comme à la télé ne surprend
pas d'accord il n'y a pas besoin de
diplôme et pas besoin de savoir et
pauvres
je sais pas de légitimité allez au poème
parce qu'à chaque fois vous entendrez
une langue 9
et qu'est ce que c'est dont on a besoin
c'est ça de l'an neuf si on lit
jaccottet que peu importe tout d'un coup
on retrouve un rapport à l'herbe au vent
oscillant ce qu'on a vu qu'on avait en
nous mais qu'on avait oublié faisait
qu'il y en a des milliers
le grès que rich aux glyphes mois que je
suis plein de poèmes dans ma tête est
plein 2 j'en ai lu tellement et chaque
fois je suis étonné surpris vous avez
pessoa le pot est magnifique tout le
monde peut lire que soit ce qu'on
pourrait de portugais les plus grands
potes de ce siècle quoi et puis je pense
à mahmoud darwish pour moi un des plus
grands poètes que la terre ait porté
vous avez un éventail je passais
formidable un bouquin coffre trésor et
ça coûte très peu cher ce fait pauvre
mais si il faut aller dans les
bibliothèques et s'ils n'ont pas boudé
hurler qu'ils aient de la pause y voilà
[Musique]
bien sûr des deux clochers tcl haute et
hi hi hi fi a été cool mais costil avec
israël